Peter we know you've got as always lots
of stuff on the go to the things you've
been working on quite recently I've got
a bit of a Brangelina connection of
Italy its Maleficent and world wars ed
now tell us a little bit first of all
about Maleficent and Maleficent is the
story of the Sleeping Beauty but told
from the point of view of the evil fairy
who causes the Sleeping Beauty the evil
fairies played by Angelina Jolie and I
play her uncle who is the king of the
fairies it is almost a very big stretch
for me clearly to be the king of the
fairies and it's wonderful it so it's a
big Disney movie with a lot of special
effects with incredible costumes and
makeup over six hours of makeup every
day to get my large pointed ears and a
pointed nose and you know you're lookin
old guy with pointed ears looks a bit
like Peter Capaldi but um it was great
it was it's a big magical terrific
moving you know story I'm dying to see
it
and then for I don't know what happened
well there was a conversation over the
table but I was asked then to be in Brad
Pitt's movie which was world wars 8 with
the zombie movies so I went from the
fairies to the zombies which was great
fun which we just finished the other
week similarly lots of special effects
being made of in that no no I was a good
deal while I was I was not a
supernatural creature I wasn't a zombie
I was just a scientist like when you're
getting all made up like that when you
remake of a 6001 you must have to get
their super early what does it feel like
when you kind of acting when you're
moving around in Monster well it's quite
weird immediately you know you get
picked up half past three in the morning
and you sit in front the mirror and they
start the stuff and if you have a little
itch in your scalp you know you're going
you're not going to scratch that itch
for 20 hours because they start it 3:30
and that's to get you ready for 11:00
it's great because you look fantastic I
mean because everybody look everybody
looks at you anything you're great you
don't you're not doing anything you're
just wearing all this work that
everybody else did
so that's lovely yeah was it like
working with Angelina and Brad as well
I'm were there they were both absolutely
lovely they were both very considerate
very welcoming
funny you know I think it must be I
genuinely think it must be really tough
to be movie stars of that status but
they're carried off with great
graciousness and consideration for other
people so I think they're very very
admirable
you